hello and welcome to this video playing
craft souk powerful moves let's see what
he's up to
he played already a couple of games and
don't quite remember how they how they
went you don't get this I'm sorry you
don't get this all that often anymore
the each five lines which are so
attractive for black but I'm quite happy
with this kind of this kind of outcome
the knight coming to e5 is giving
interesting play okay so he wants to
give me the bishop air just like that
all it seems
I mean I don't really see a big point in
provoking age six if you just like
return our to you three what what was
the benefit so it seems that he intends
to take on is seven and it's hard to
believe I mean one thing that needs to
be mentioned is that I'd only mind this
night only seven because he's 65 it's a
very typical way of playing this in
particular this c6 make sure that the
bishop on g2 is not as active and you
have an easier development of the
queenside another idea is be form like
in this for white okay is playing before
and then you often can activate this why
I'm beard so the drawback of all the
stuff is that now c4 is weak so now is
white going to go t5 may it's not
ridiculous you can do that
d5 takes no it takes and just
yeah it's actually better than I thought
so now do I take with the bishop or with
the noid Bishop jinx
[Music]
now this is more conventional
yam problem structural point of view
this looks bad with a pawn on d6 and a
square on d5 given up but yeah this is a
good Bishop song let's see him yeah he
wants to go to the five of course
[Music]
let's go Queen to b6 that's an
interesting one
I'm attacking before and I intend to be
five with the tempo okay yeah well the
night will come to d5 but this is not
the end of the world really if I have
the the e-file that is also worth
something now here when p5 becomes and
it is an additional resource also there
is rookie for it's remarkable him that
night looks very very strong but it is
not so clear because I have some assets
as well
interesting
b5 Queen c5 cannot be cannot be a big
issue
I might even have rook G for like this
and this it would be funny okay I wanted
to go just Here I am keep an eye on b6
and let's see form this is still
attacked I mean I can now do we play
hooky form rook e1 as a funny move it's
a bit of a shocker
don't know if it's good though it's
probably this is this is probably not
actually good rook e1 and it's got 12
seconds okay come on
okay okay Jew well how do we do this the
other look to each oh I didn't I didn't
in spot that actually it's a bit silly
but take c4 there's b6
that's ridiculous come on
oh man that's totally ridiculous whoo
Thunder God should oh my god oh I'm such
an idiot my god ed this position was so
utterly winning and I i blundered it
into this crap I'm sorry I came and I
totally lost control them yeah I'm such
a [ __ ] really I think yeah here I mean
I'm just fine just fine and then I'm
blundering this away okay so yeah I
don't think that Bishop g5 can be good
just gifting me the bishop pair it
cannot be too too great but I mean
obviously White's position is quite
solid zone it's not nothing special
going on so why now this d5 business
yeah this is interesting I mean that is
not photo spittle I should be okay here
Queen b6 is a temporal move and another
tempo or a mr. c5 okay now that's bad
hmmm that's bad so whoopsy eight is
about acquire yeah so that was a big
opportunity mc5 may have to have
children go into this
maybe I'm getting the deep one back
somehow but that is a hope tough okay he
didn't see that is understandable Quinn
d3 doubling and this is not really
interesting a foreign key for also I
know there was a decently play game I
can't take c4 of course but I wanted to
keep the tension down I mean I saw I saw
this and I wasn't quite sure what what
this is could couldn't quite believe
that this is good
so Queen c5 and now rook e1 there was
really a chanting move with the time
down I can do other things of course
this is the possibility but it doesn't
seem to be good okay hmm
taketake Queen D force
it's the engines primary recommendation
so this this and now Knight c3 after
which I'm supposed to capture now that
is certainly equal okay yeah rook e1 is
more of a show move than anything else
he played this and now I should should
play this of course I know I completely
did not recycle Italy missed that you
can take you won it was and this is not
really this is not really comfortable
king f7 was a bit of a I don't know what
did you move Queen D for am I need to go
I need to get I need to get this
here I really played badly really badly
a five is already pretty bad and g5 was
just entirely stupid I mean and yeah I'm
just totally lost really totally lost
king g6 mistake out cam and it's already
- million M yeah okay this is not as
good but what can you do
okay oh wow
I mean of course white could have worn
it I think it's funny that if he goes
King edge to now it is still winning for
what it is still winning even though he
blundered this thing was Czech I mean
I'm in a meeting net here he is
threatening G for this this Andrew cage
six mate and the G for Luke II to e6 is
also bit of a disaster yeah I was one of
the luckiest twins I can can remember
yeah
increment or not yet the end it's often
just hectic him okay yes thanks for
watching